[Musique]
c'est une annonce qui a fait le tour du
monde hier et qui a fait grimper en
flèche les bourses financières celles du
laboratoire américain pfizer qui annonce
avoir réalisé un vaccin contre le coc
vite 19 efficace à 90%
une annonce choc qui pourrait changer la
face du monde si le vaccin n'est pas
encore tout à fait prêt la phase iii des
tests qui a permis d'évaluer
l'efficacité sur près de 40000 cobaye
est en cours et se veut très optimiste
les américains auraient la priorité sur
ce vaccin 50 millions de doses devraient
être prêtes d'ici la fin de l'année 2020
pour les états unis
du côté européen de 100 millions de
doses ont été commandées des doses qui
pourrait être vendu aux alentours de
16h50 l'une pour le plus gros de la
livraison des vaccins il faudra donc
attendre 2021 ou 1,3 milliard de doses
seront produites mais encore faut-il que
tout le monde souhaite se faire vacciner
car en france seulement 54% de la
population se dit prête à franchir le
cap
deux raisons à ça les opposants au
vaccin qui refusent cette méthode depuis
toujours mais aussi ceux qui trouvent
que la fabrication de ce vaccin est allé
trop vite sauf que voilà il est
essentiel qu'une très grande partie de
la population se vaccine pour que cela
fonctionne alors vous feriez vous
vacciner
le professeur frédéric amené chef de
service à l'hôpital avicenne nous donne
son avis
avec no mercy chef du service des
urgences à l'hôpital avicenne un grand
hôpital et un grand professeur merci
d'être avec nous professeur amenez votre
livre les fantassins de la république
merci vous l'avez d'éducation plus ça
m'a fait extrêmement plaisir
merci d'être là vous expliquez
extrêmement bien à chaque fois alors
déjà ce vaccin prêt à 90 %
c'est une bonne nouvelle quand même à
c'est plus qu'une bonne nouvelle c'est
un espoir énorme pour nous et nous on
voit on en accueille les malades ou
nakheel est malade dans l'animation on
voit les malades mourir on voit les
malades et/ou faire ça on l'a vu pour la
première vague on était complètement
submergé ce que je décris dans le livre
mais là c'est 2-2 puis on a une marée
montante l'hôpital est rempli de ces
malades et si on arrive on arrivait à
arrêter le coc vide à arrêter de cette
épidémie pour arrêter le virus est pas
le confinement 1 pour arrêter le virus
est en soi une immunité collective soit
le vaccin
et si on arrivait à arrêter le pourquoi
d'après les infos que vous avez écouté
le communiqué de presse alors c'est pas
orthodoxe en général c'est une
publication scientifique qui nous donne
les tous les détails là on a un
communiqué de presse de father carla et
avec un laboratoire allemand qui nous
disent qu'ils auront quelques millions
de doses fin 2020 et 1,5 milliard
d'euros dans un mois quoi exactement de
1,25 milliard de doses fin 2021 alors
lorsqu'ils voient les savoirs parce que
tout le monde dit ça va être d'abord les
autres pays qui vont être servis non
parce que c'est une collaboration
attention l'inventeur du vaccin c'est un
laboratoire allemand
d'accord c'est un la vente en allemand
et fighter à quai en back office pour
fabriquer sa et le diffuser mondialement
et donc la distribution à mon avis va
être à égalité avec l'europe
donc la france et les états unis qu'en
france on va pouvoir se faire vacciner
ou penser fin 2020 m'attendais il faut
d'abord être sûr que ce soit ainsi si ça
marche si ça va que ça marche il tient
ses promesses s'ils assurent une
immunité un peu plus long puisqu'il
était évaluée simplement à 28 jours
après l'aller
début de la vaccination donc c'est très
court en terme d' immunité mais si cette
immunité dure plusieurs mois
ce qu'on espère tous on pense que on
aura ou pour être vaccinés dans le
courant en 2021 alors professeur a donné
juste la question que tous se posent
c'est on étant donné qu'il a été créé et
très vite on connaît pas les effets
secondaires de ce vaccin
sk pas plein de personnes regardez ici
on leur a demandé s'ils allaient se
faire vacciner ou pas la majorité de nos
rôles de mon dossier téléspectateurs il
y en a plein qui disent nous le jeu vous
dit ce qu'il se passe dans la tête des
nourrices 10 mine de rien lakovic 19 bon
on voit j'ai plein de potes qui l'ont
eue moi c'est pas non plus très très
grave imaginons que peut faire vacciner
j'ai des effets secondaires qui peuvent
être beaucoup plus grave que si j'avais
l'aco vide
donc je préfère ne pas me faire vacciner
alors si on posait la question
aujourd'hui évidemment je suis comme
vous tous je dirais non parce que
l'étude n'ait pas fini mes études
et si l'étude est que si l'étude est
fini si on démontre sur les quelques
dizaines de milliers de volontaires
sains qui a aucun effet secondaire que
le virus s'est arrêté à 90% je vous
rappelle que pour un vaccin tout qu'il
soit efficace il doit être au dessus de
60 70% là c'est 90%
s'il n'y a aucun effet secondaire sur
les dizaines de milliers de volontaires
et si on me prouve que l'immunité est
efficace et plus longue que les 28 jours
évidemment je serai le premier à
vacciner alors moi pas forcément pour
moi c'est aussi pour mes patients parce
que le personnel soignant doit se faire
vacciner pour pas transmettre le virus à
ses patients alors regardez une info qui
vient de sortir flac effets secondaires
du vaccin de pfizer
plusieurs participants déclarant avoir
eu des maux de tête et de la tienne ils
comparent leurs sensations et une gueule
de bois sévère alors ça c'est un peu
mais souvent quand on fait un vaccin
contre la grippe on est malade dans les
effets secondaires on distingue deux
sortes d'effets on distingue les effets
secondaires graves les événements
indésirables graves qui entraîne un
risque pour la santé et des effets
secondaires moins graves qui sont
communs tous les vaccins par exemple la
douleur au point d'injection d'accord un
petit fait briques une fièvre un jour ou
deux quelques mots tête ça c'est des
effets secondaires attendus pour
n'importe quel vaccin
donc ça fait partie des effets
secondaires pas grave les effets
secondaires graves s'est développé une
maladie
gravi municipal savoir un décès abassi
puisque tous les patients ces dizaines
de milliers de patients sont suivis sont
suivis pendant toutes les mèches blondes
et le temps nécessaire pour voir si
là-bas c'est pour ça que c'est des
résultats préliminaires c'est à dire que
l'étude est là et et design et elles
étaient fabriquées pour durer un certain
nombre d'années en général c'est 1,1 en
deux ans là on donne des résultats
préliminaires pas ce qu'est l'urgence
sanitaire et pour l'instant ce qu'ils
produisent qu'il publie dans ce
communiqué passe bien sûr faut le
vérifier dans une publication
scientifique
pour l'instant ce vaccin a l'air
sécurisé en termes d'effets secondaires
et efficace en terme de d'efficacité
pour créer une réponse est mieux c'est
quand même il ya quand même de très très
bonne nouvelle c'est une très très bonne
citerai pas que c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est un très très bon espoir alors il
ya pas mal de gens qui dînent aussi que
la moitié des doses de vaccin contre la
corée du nord aurait déjà été réservées
par un groupe de pays riches
ces pays ne représente pourtant que 13 %
de la population mondiale il ya déjà
voilà des gens qui disent que ce sera
décidée qu'au pays arabes seuls pays bas
il faut bien savoir qu'il ya des enjeux
financiers énormes que je suis pas dans
le secret des dieux je vais pas
participer aux négociations pour la
charge de ce vaccin
ce qui me rassure moi c'est que c'est
une coopération entre l'europe
l'allemagne et les etats-unis alors
l'allemagne qui a le mieux géré la crise
en plus ils vont nous trouver le
médicament contre le commun et donc sont
très très fort mais je pense qu'il doit
avoir une coopération donc entre
l'europe et les états unis et
probablement qu'il y aura une
distribution juste du vaccin alors
n'allez pas vous faire vacciner va avoir
d'autres infos 1 dans un instant ou non
mais moi ça me fait un peu peur parce
que je trouve qu'effectivement ça va ça
va très vite après on verra dans
quelques mois mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on dit on est en train de
parler du nombre de doses on connaît pas
le nombre de doses qui serait suffisante
pour être immunisé on sait pas si on
doit vous en faire tous les six mois ou
si on leur en faire plusieurs là je
dirais qu'on est je crois qu'on est en
phase iii cessa de développement donc la
phase iii s'est pas non plus c'est bien
la blackhat phase 4 4 et puis après il
ya la food drug administration qui doit
valider mais le géant n'est qu'en phase
iii donc c'est un peu mais rien pas de
phase iv a pas de face qu'à une phase 4
à la phase passée ça qui va donner
l'autorisation sur le marché
c'est-à-dire la phase 3 c'est la
dernière étape c'est l'essai clinique
bien avancée quand on prend des
zen milliers de patients en fin de vie
les effets secondaires et ainsi le
professeur a menée dit qu'on aura dans
n'aura pour fin 2009 s'est lassé dans un
oui j le garder mais moins il me ferait
presque changé d'avis mais quand même
professeur j'ai peur j'ai peur de ce
vaccin j'ai peur que la boe uniquement
et envie de monter en bourse en flèche
comme il l'a fait j'ai peur de
l'approximation des effets secondaires
et puis après on nous dit il faut leur
elle conservé dans un congélateur à des
températures très froides 80 a pas les
moyens en france donc je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup d'approximations ça me fait
voilà mais au contraire frémir quoi si
on me demandait aujourd'hui je dirais
comme vous non et vous avez le même
argument que moi ben alors que l'essai
clinique est terminée oui alors que ce
qu'ils aient prévu était finie que tous
les patients étaient au pouvoir conclure
si côté subi ces bons résultats
préliminaires c'est pas du tout des
résultats définitifs donc c'est pour ça
que c'est un espoir c'est un espoir que
ce vaccin puisse marcher
prenez oui je suis content qu'ils aient
ça nous fait plaisir si vous êtes
content mais pas ce qui pourra lui il ya
que lui qui pour la mer le pana ce que
je vais dire voilà moi je me à flers
s'est jamais fait bakshi mais de quoi
que ce soit je n'ai jamais été malade et
pour une raison
j'ai fait l'armée les enseignes qui ont
fait l'armée comme moi le savez je suis
un termite 67
ils m'ont fait une [ __ ] des piqûres de
cheval alors c'était pas si on était
obligé de de rester en chambre et trois
jours tellement elle était puissante et
les militaires de l'époque nous lisez
vous savez cette piqûre vous a fait mal
mais vous immunise avis pour beaucoup de
changements beaucoup de choses et non
pas 10 pour tous est maintenant dans ma
vie et j'ai jamais eu du jour de maladie
je suis jamais
[Musique]
parce que si vous avez jamais été malade
parce que les autres sont humides sont
aussi ne sais pas ce que les autres
n'ont pas du tout compliqué la maladie
est ce qu'elle a joué sept voiliers si
ça peut pas aider l'egypte à lever très
libertines l emploi le mais peut-être
que ça n'intéressait pas les
laboratoires que de professionnels de
piqûres le vaccinateur michel d'accès
vers saint louis
donc c'est plutôt l'investissent kida
immunisés je pense à la banque pour
parler de choses sérieuses en effet
l'armée on a été vaccinée parce que
l'alarmé et beaucoup de gens qui mènent
la campagne qui n'avaient pas été
vaccinés nouveau max né systématiquement
tout le monde pour les vaccins
classiques beaucoup mon professeur à
mener donc là on blacks ont résumé si la
phase iii se passe bien il ya aucun
risque il faut se faire vacciner vous
dites alors si la phase iii ce pas faim
se passe bien
si le vaccin est efficace il provoque
une immunité durable et s'il n'y a pas
d'effets secondaires il faut absolument
rebondir même plus tard non mais si la
phase iii on enfoncera sont toutes sur
des dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
de volontaires donc on est sur un procès
ce qui est normal pour valider un vaccin
comme tous les autres vaccins valait
quand les vaccins ont été validées il ya
jamais eu si vous voulez de catastrophes
liées un vaccin je rappelle que le
vaccin permis de sauver des millions de
vies humaines c'est probablement le
progrès médical le plus important des
derniers siècles la variole a disparu
grâce et grâce aux vaccins des maladies
graves et simon ont disparu grâce au
vaccin
si vous n'avez pas été vacciné je répète
je le répète je vous dirai pas ce que
tout le monde savait mais professeur
année il ya une petite différence entre
toutes les maladies que vous venez de
citer et lakovic 19 lakovic 19
on le voit il ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont pas peur la comédienne on le voit
même lors de ce confinement des fonds
voit ya plein de gens premier
confinement est celle qui avait très
peur de la halle de la frapper là on
sent que les gens ont moins peur du
maillot on a tous eu un pote qui l'a eu
j'ai eu un pote dieu quelques trucs
franchement il va bien donc là on se dit
est ce qu'on va prendre le risque de se
faire vacciner même si tout à l'air ok
parce que c'est pas c'est vrai que c'est
le petit truc qui est un petit peu
mais en tous les cas moi je vois les
gens mourir et je suis jeune et je vois
des jeunes mourir et je les vois tous
les jour mourir
donc mon hôpital est rempli et rempli de
malades très grave y compris des jeunes
y compris des ma dernière guerre j'ai eu
deux patients de moins de 30 ans qui ont
été en réanimation intime et qui vont
peut-être pas s'en sortir
je vois je vois tous les jours dans mon
service des gens attrapent les locaux
vides
j'ai dit médecin au tapis moi j'ai une
équipe de 60 médecins les dix médecins
au tapis dont deux qui ont été
hospitalisés qui ont développé la forme
grave des jeunes donc non c'est pas une
année pas une grippette c'est pas une
grippette c'est pas une grippe
bien sûr chez les jeunes on peut avoir
des proches qui ont eu le cou aux idées
et s'en sortent sans problème mais quand
vous quand vous cherchez bien quand vous
parlez à vos parents vos grands parents
me connaissent des proches qui sont
décédés hier au brésil vous avez vu que
le vaccin était suspendu en plein test
brésil je suis un excellent secondaire
louis voilà il ya eu un décès il ya eu
des signes involontaire je connais je
connais la sphère a eu un décès sur donc
la phase iii donc ça arrêter la phase 3
il ya une enquête qu'il se fait pour
voir si cette mort est attribuable aux
vaccins si elle l'est ça va arrêter
complètement lâché et c'est ça c'est que
je suis sûr ça se voulait que je suis
rassuré c'est à dire que dans ces essais
puis les mannequins rigole pas avec ces
essais cliniques ainsi pas d'henri c'est
qui va faire à la va vite
s'il ya un effet indésirable grave qui
se fait en arêtes où on fait une enquête
et si cet effet indésirable grave est
lié au vaccin à ce mot là bas la vaccin
a perdu de son acuité delhi voulait dire
que oui moi j'avais j'avais une question
j'aimerais savoir quand un vaccin est
créé est terminé
phase 3 comme vous l'avez dit
généralement on compte combien de mois
ou combien d'années pour être sûr qu'il
n'y a pas de répercussion long terme
alors après c'est ce qu'on appelle la
phase 4 d'ailleurs la forme rien d'autre
alors c'est à dire que tous les
accidents liés à l'utilisation d'un
médicament sont signalés à l'année c'est
mal autorités de santé et il ya une
enquête épidémiologique il se fait pour
savoir si l'effet indésirable est lié au
vaccin ou autres chaînes généralement
ces bulles même temps c'est là que ça
dure toute la vie du médicament
je vaccine quelqu'un et je m'aperçois
qu'ils développent une maladie et que je
pense que c'est lié à mon vaccin je le
déclare être se met en route alors jadot
qu'a dit sur france info qu'il
souhaitait justement que votre futur
vaccin anti corrida soit un vaccin
obligatoire c'est d'accord avec lui si
tous les tests sont bons non je ne pense
pas c'est une question intéressante mais
écouter ceux qui font la forme grave du
coc vide c'est des gens qui ont en
général plus de 60 ans donc ces gens qui
savent résonnait moi je crois beaucoup à
la pédagogie je crois beaucoup à
responsabiliser les les personnes et
savait en médecine d'urgence on a des
patients comme ça qu'ils ont un
infarctus qui ont un avc qui veulent pas
les l'hôpital qui veulent pas cherché à
nier on peut pas obliger les gens à
faire soigner donc je pense que en
expliquant bien l'innocuité d'un du
futur vaccin si ça marche en
responsabilisant les les patients et ses
patients il savait savent qu'ils sont un
facteur de risque si le combat de
vacciner en premier
peut-être que l'obligation devrait être
fait pour les soignants parce que nous
on a quand même une probabilité non nul
de le transmettre aux malades
mais pour la population générale je
crois qu'il faut les convaincre qu'il
faut se faire vacciner si on te regarde
et will santé cyril vous plaît allez
vous vous faire vacciner oui oui enfin
tu % de nos 79 72 %